fragile ceasefire between israel and
hamas is in its second day and has
already been
tested palestinians and israeli police
briefly clashed at jerusalem's al-aqsa
mosque
friday with security forces firing tear
gas
the 11-day battle killed more than 200
people most of them in gaza some
children
it also left large-scale destruction
president biden says a two-state
solution is the best way to end the
fighting
meanwhile the united nations has
approved more than 18 million dollars in
humanitarian relief efforts
holly williams is in gaza this morning
holly good morning
good morning while the conflict was
still raging the israeli government
would not allow us
into the gaza strip they said for our
own security
now that we're finally here we can show
you the scale of the destruction
buildings literally torn off their
foundations by airstrikes
and over here you can see people sifting
through the rubble
for their belongings
in gaza with the ceasefire holding for
now
palestinians are taking stock of what
they lost in this conflict
it's opened new wounds in a place
already worn down by
poverty told us she's mourning
family friends who once lived where
there's now
only rubble oh my friends this family
and my friends
that mom
hamas the group that controls the gaza
strip
labelled a terrorist organization by the
u.s celebrated the ceasefire as a
victory
they fired over 4 000 rockets at israeli
towns and cities killing 13.
though israel's iron dome air defense
system
shot down most of the projectiles
israel's retaliation was to pummel the
overcrowded gaza strip
where they have no defense
the israeli government claims it did
unprecedented damage to hamas
killing more than 200 militants while
doing its best to avoid civilians
but officials here say nearly 70 of
those killed
were children five-month-old baby omar
lost his four brothers
and mother in a strike
my heart is breaking his father muhammad
told us
what guilt does this baby have muhammad
denies that he's a militant
and could have been the target for
israel though we can't
independently confirm that
there are two versions of what happened
in this conflict
and the ceasefire which is precarious
does nothing to fix the real problem
which is two peoples fighting over the
same piece of land
which they both call home for cbs this
morning saturday holly williams
gaza